arriesgándose a la ira de la iglesia el
padre giorgi de 89 años es uno de los
pocos sacerdotes ortodoxos de rusia que
se opone a la guerra en ucrania desde su
casa a orillas del río volga a 6 horas
en auto de moscú con su barba blanca y
sotana negra reflexiona sobre el tema
con voz temblorosa pero sin vacilar
y me temo que soy un mal sacerdote nunca
estaba en contra de todas las guerras
pero sí en contra de las guerras
agresivas de conquista
el padre de giorgi luego del inicio de
la guerra hizo una carta que fue
publicada en el sitio web de su
parroquia en la región de kostromá al
oeste de rusia acción que fue condenada
por el jefe de la diócesis de la región
pero los cuestionamientos no terminaron
ahí durante una misa otro padre expresó
su descontento sobre la invasión rusa
ese mismo día fue citado en una
comisaría y recibió una multa por 35 mil
rublos unos 440 euros en caso de
reincidir podría ir tres años a prisión
el mandamiento no matarás es para mí
incondicional como los demás
no importa lo que se intenta poner
mediano especial de carbón ya no
importan como situaciones de límites y
granizo
la iglesia ortodoxa rusa ha estado
restringida y bajo el control de la
unión soviética incluso después de su
disolución en 1991 desde entonces no se
han emitido críticas a ninguna autoridad
desde que comenzó a dirigir la y grecia
todo observa trial que adquirir ha
estrechado sus lazos con el presidente
putin sin cuestionar la guerra
recientemente como es tradicional putin
asistió a la misa por las pascuas donde
el patriarca oficio la misa desde que
rusia lanzó su ofensiva militar el 24 de
febrero muy pocos sacerdotes del iglesia
ortodoxa se han expresado sin titular en
contra de la invasión rusa sin embargo
unos pocos empiezan a hacerlo